i i but i think that's an incredibly
relevant question and i think doj in the
same way that it is uh setting up a task
force to investigate oligarchs should
look into people who are russian
propagandists and shilling for putin
that's being if you are a foreign asset
uh to a dictator it should be
investigated in fact i remember when
tulsi gabbard and i even hate that we're
discussing it because i think to myself
who is this woman she's a you know she's
no longer in congress she's a failed
presidential candidate she only
practically exists on twitter and the
fact that we're giving her oxygen is
what makes her relevant that we're
talking about her on hot topics but on
the other hand how do you not call out
something that is repeating
false russian propaganda and that has
been brought down they used to arrest
people for doing stuff like this if they
thought you were
colluding with a russian agent if they
thought you were putting out information
or taking information and handing over
to russia they used to actually
investigate stuff like this and i guess
now you know there seems to be no bars
what are you two crazy [ __ ] talking
about what are you talking about you
want to arrest people who are different
than you politically tulsi gabbard she's
a member of our military she's a former
congresswoman a democrat you just don't
like her so you want to arrest her you
ought to arrest tucker carlson the very
dapper tucker carlson
what are you saying you you guys are
nuts you're just nuts i only agreed to
do this show because i thought that
whoopi whoopie was sane she was good
sister act sister act two
anna's just nuts i don't even know what
she's doing here the other ones are
racist the the there's the drunk one
what is what are we all doing here
you people are everything that you've
come to hate you know that
uh
why am i here
i need a haircut
okay that's better
hello there i'm dave rubin this is the
reuben report direct message on today
march 15 2022 we are live streaming on
rumble youtube and blaze tv although
after that we may not be live streaming
on youtube
much longer uh yes that was incredible
unearthed unedited
secret footage
from
the view yesterday that was guest host
darlene rudin
who was laying down the truth with those
lunatics
that's what we're doing around here
that's what we discussed doing around
here at 8 am in the morning don't ask
how we got the wig
michael had to go to target pick out a
few blouses for me and the lipstick
great choice in color by the way michael
really really nailed it
um i was very concerned because i didn't
i've never put on lipstick before
believe it or not and i was very worried
that i wasn't gonna be able to get it
off for the show but it all kind of
worked out i even managed to get a
haircut
this morning um but those women of the
view are completely insane i hope you
enjoy that i think we may start doing a
little more of that that sort of thing
because basically me
in drag as a drunk psychotic lunatic
sitting with those women is more sane
than anything that they're doing right
now because as you know the view is on
live uh at 11 a.m eastern as are we
and if you watch the view
if you're watching the view right now
you're in a very different world than
most of you guys who are watching this
right now i mean it's just absolutely
insane anyway speaking of insanity uh
we've got really i would say a banana's
show for you and and we're gonna do a
real dissection of what's going on in in
the world right now you know i've been
trying to not
drug you guys over the head with the
russia ukraine stuff i've talked a
little bit about it and i've been trying
to talk about the media coverage of it
but the simple truth is it is almost
impossible to figure out who to trust on
this right now the people that lie to us
about everything or seemingly pushing us
into war calling for no-fly zones as if
that doesn't bring you to war but you
know if there's a no-fly zone and a
plane flies in you got to shoot down the
plane next thing you know you got war
it's just like everyone lies about
everything so if they lie to you
about absolutely everything right all
the stuff that you guys know they lie
about they lie about all that if the
machine lies about all that stuff is
this the one thing they're telling us
the truth on i just don't know i'm
trying to get an honest assessment of
thing but i don't trust of this thing
but i don't trust obviously jen saki i
don't trust joe biden i don't trust the
new york times i don't trust the
washington post they don't deserve our
trust so i'm trying to make some sense
of it one person who i roughly trust
though roughly is tulsi gabbard who i
think is a decent human being who is one
of the few same democrats running for
president who is a former congressman
from a congresswoman from hawaii uh who
you know i've interviewed a few times
and i consider her friend and is like a
decent human being and she's she's
raising some concerns about what's going
on over there and uh what we're going to
frame the show around today is that mitt
romney
you know the swamp creature mitt romney
is basically calling her treasonous and
the women of the viewer calling for her
to be arrested basically along with
tucker carlson so that's what we're
going to really focus on today real
quick though i want to remind you guys
that don't burn this country is coming
out on april 12th you can pre-order it
right now at daverubin.com
book and if you pre-order it it counts
as first week orders so i can get back
on that new york times list even though
i don't care about the new york times
new york times list which makes it even
funnier to be on there and if you go to
davereuben.com you can buy it from
amazon or barnes and nobles or your
local bookstore a couple other retailers
we will have a big announcement this
week regarding the tour i'm hoping that
i can announce it tomorrow and then i
think we're going to do a pre-sale of
tour tickets for our locals community
reubenreport.locals.com
on thursday and then the general public
on friday so hopefully we can announce
that tomorrow and uh all right i got a
little lipstick oh i'm feeling good
let's talk about jen yourself for just a
moment and then we will get to the show
ladies and gentlemen let me tell you
about janusel's new ultra retinol cream
which uses dual action skin technology
to visibly reduce and improve red
inflamed and yes even blotchy skin by
combining hyaluronic acid and a
breakthrough phytoretinal you too can
smooth away forehead wrinkles and laugh
lines plus renew and revitalize your
appearance without the harsh effects and
irritation of retinol geniusell
ultraretinol is safe for sensitive skin
provides effective hydration and skin
renewing benefits for all skin types and
is perfect for both men and women or men
who are youtubers who occasionally dress
up like women to mock the ladies of the
view go to genusl.com dave now for up to
50 off the brand new ultra retinol serum
you'll also get jen you sell immediate
effects for results in 12 hours or less
for free with your order that's an 89
value free express shipping free returns
exquisite customer service you'll be
amazed with the results or you'll get
your money back just go to genyasal.com
dave that's g-e-n-u-c-e-l
dot com dave and now back to me uh is it
weird that i kept the bra
i just felt it
just kind of keeping it all in place you
know what i'm saying all right let's
talk about what's going on here with
this russia ukraine stuff and
misinformation and who to trust
and everything else so the big thing
over the last couple of days is that
apparently
there are bio
labs okay biological labs in ukraine
potentially funded by the united states
and here is secretary of state for
political affairs victoria nuland being
questioned by marco rubio at a
congressional hearing about these bio
labs and whether they're weaponized or
not and who might be in charge of them
and what could happen if russia goes for
them and that's going to really set up
the rest of the show today take a look
does ukraine have chemical or biological
weapons
uh ukraine has a
biological research facilities
which in fact we are now quite concerned
russian troops russian forces
may be seeking to
uh gain control of so we are working
with the ukrainians on how they can
prevent any of those
research materials from falling into the
hands of
russian forces should they approach i'm
sure you're aware that the russian
propaganda
groups are already putting out there all
kinds of information about how they've
uncovered a plot by the ukrainians to
release biological weapons in the
country and with nato's coordination if
there's a biological or chemical weapon
incident or uh or attack inside of
ukraine is there any doubt in your mind
that 100 percent would be the russians
that would be behind it there is no
doubt in my mind senator and it is
classic russian
uh technique to blame on the other guy
what they're planning to do themselves
okay there's victoria newlin talking
about the ukrainians who more so sound
like something from star trek i think
she means ukrainians but putting that
aside for a moment so okay so in essence
there are these bio labs they are not
weaponized they are research labs but of
course if bad guys could get a hold of
the material there you don't have to be
a biologist or a weapons expert to
understand if you can get a hold of
these pathogens that could make people
sick god only knows what they're doing
in these labs that they could be
weaponized they're not being designed to
be weapons that basically is what she's
saying and and rubio there is saying hey
if if somebody does something and this
thing blows up uh is this going to be
the russians she's saying without a
question it will be i don't know how you
could really know that before it's
happened like anyone could do anything
or blow up anything for whatever their
reasons might be there could be an
accident that blows up the thing
anyway
what brings this all up is that tulsi
gabbard
put out a video basically saying that
there should be a ceasefire around these
bio labs to just kind of cool the
tensions regardless of what you think is
exactly going on here regardless of what
you think about russia ukraine
everything else tulsi put this video out
and then there was some fallout from
mitt romney so first let's look at the
video here are the undeniable facts
there are 25 to 30 u.s funded bio labs
in ukraine
according to the us government these bio
labs are conducting research on
dangerous pathogens
ukraine is in an active war zone with
widespread bombing artillery and
shelling and
these facilities
even in the best of circumstances could
easily be compromised and release these
deadly pathogens
so in order to protect the american
people the people of europe the people
around the world
these labs need to be shut down
immediately and the pathogens that they
hold need to be destroyed
instead of trying to cover this up the
biden-harris administration needs to
work with russia ukraine nato the u.n to
immediately implement a ceasefire for
all military action the vicinity of
these labs until they're secured
and these pathogens are destroyed
now this is not a partisan political
issue
the administration and congress need to
act now for the health and well-being of
every american
and every person on this planet
you know how i always say that thing
about when someone is telling the truth
which is so rare these days you can sort
of feel it right like she's making a
point this is not partisan
these bio labs exist there are pathogens
that could get out what the substance to
all of this is that we just got out of
two years of covid you would not want
more pathogens out there to start
another worldwide pandemic she's saying
instead of obfuscating the truth around
this related to who funded it or what's
going on there or anything else but
there is a war zone there are bombs
going off artillery things are blowing
up this is woman who knows a bit about
war she's an active member of our
military actually i wanted her on the
show a couple weeks ago to discuss
something else entirely and she was
doing training okay so this is not
somebody who is just making this stuff
up or has no information about any of
this on top of the fact that she's a
former congresswoman uh and she's just a
decent human like right like it's just
obvious this is a decent human so all
she's saying is hey there's a war
there's biolabs everybody better figure
out how to make sure that these things
don't fall into the wrong hands or get
blown up and start another pandemic
that's in essence what she is saying
well then mitt romney saw that and
listen to what mitt romney said on the
twitter he said tulsi gabbard is
parroting false russian propaganda her
and here's the word treasonous lies
may well cost lives okay
first off
does anything that she said there sound
like a treasonous lie
or does it sound like
concern
concerned that there are biolabs with
some dangerous stuff in a war zone
so what are the facts the facts are
there is a war zone the facts are that
there was victoria nuland admitting that
these bio labs exist all tulsa is saying
is hey we better watch out for this uh
mitt romney who yeah i'm being told
four-time draft dodger mitt romney is
saying to a current member of our
military that she is treasonous this is
this is an extraordinary claim by mitt
romney mitt romney who has
been sort of the worst nothingness
republican stands up for nothing other
than continuing to feed the machine
well tulsi is not laying down and just
taking it from mitch she sent out quite
a quite a good twitter thread she said
at mitt romney you have called me a
treasonous liar for stating the fact
that there are 25 plus u.s funded bio
labs in ukraine which if breached would
release and spread deadly pathogens to
the us and world and therefore must be
secured in order to prevent new
pandemics bizarrely you claim that
securing these labs or even calling for
securing these labs is treasonous and
will lead to a loss of life when the
exact opposite is obviously true the
spread of pathogens is what will cause
the loss of life not the prevention of
such spread
senator romney please provide evidence
that what i said is untrue and
treasonous if you cannot you should do
the honorable thing
apologize and resign from the senate
evidence of the existence of such
biolabs their vulnerability and thus the
need to take immediate action to secure
them is beyond dispute
everything that tulsi said right there
oh sorry there was one more piece on
this so senator romney you have a choice
out of pride continue to deny the truth
or admit that you are wrong apologize
and resign aloha and remember that
without truth
we can be neither safe nor
free
man
tulsi great freaking thread sister
she lays out her argument again
she pokes holes in romney's nothingness
all he does is is call her treasonous
and a liar he offers no evidence of it
he doesn't deny and to this point as of
five minutes ago when we started the
show he has not publicly denied anything
that she said we just showed you
victoria nuland saying that the bio labs
exist anyone would understand that in a
war zone if you've got bio labs it's a
problem it would be like if you dropped
a bomb on a nuclear reactor you might
have a problem we all understand this
stuff so i think tulsi not only did that
with
with grace and humility
but it's on romney right now it's on
romney and i don't think he really cares
about truth i don't know what he cares
about but what are you saying what is
treasonous
about what tulsi gabbard said but we
just let these people say these things
and then they get rewarded on the talk
shows and on all of the programs so here
is
the view
and it's the original clip that we did
our cold open with this is the ladies of
the view basically calling for tulsi and
tucker to be investigated and
potentially arrested
but i think that's an incredibly
relevant question and i think doj in the
same way that it is uh setting up a task
force to investigate oligarchs should
look into people who are russian
propagandists and shilling for putin
that's being if you are a foreign asset
to a dictator it should be investigated
in fact i remember when tulsi gabbard
and i even hate that we're discussing it
because i think to myself who is this
woman she's a you know she's no longer
in congress she's a failed presidential
candidate she only practically exists on
twitter and the fact that we're giving
her oxygen is what makes her relevant
that we're talking about her on hot
topics but on the other hand how do you
not call out something that is repeating
false russian propaganda that has been
brought down they used to arrest people
for doing stuff like this if they
thought you were
uh colluding with a russian agent if
they thought you were putting out
information or taking information and
handing over to russia they used to
actually investigate stuff like this and
i guess now you know there seems to be
no bars
i get it guys i owe you an apology
because i now showed you that clip twice
the first one was better with
me and drag
um but these people are crazy like
they're legitimately crazy what is
whoopi saying they used to investigate
they used to arrest you oh so we should
just start investigating more people who
for wrong think right um they used to
grab them and put them in jail and
gulags and no trials or anything like
that and that crazy anna navarro who is
just she reeks of being just a horrible
horrible person
like what are you saying anna navarro
what what are you really really saying
yes tulsi gabbard is irrelevant she's
only relevant because you talk about her
on on hot topics um and she's a failed
presidential candidate well a she was a
congresswoman uh i believe a two-term
congresswoman
who really did
uh do something relevant during the
campaign she actually stayed in the
campaign longer than anybody else
other than joe biden the machine decided
to choose joe biden but tulsi stayed and
fought as long as she could but if she's
a failed presidential candidate what are
you anna navarro you've worked for a
whole bunch of uh people political
people as a consultant who have all
failed so so you're you're nothing but
an angry harping you're awful these
people they're just awful and these are
supposedly the people who are tolerant
and they're the ones that are talking
about arresting their political
opponents and on top of the fact that
everything that they're talking about is
based on nonsense they're they're saying
she's parroting russia propaganda but we
just showed you that actually what she's
referring to is what victoria nuland is
admitting is real that these bio labs
exist
okay so then there's this lunatic
another lunatic these people are crazy
they are crazy and we all have to decide
how much attention we want to pay to
them
there's this guy he was a sports center
anchor 25 years ago and he was pretty
good keith olbermann and then he became
an msnbc host and he went completely
insane uh let's put up this tweet by
keith orman he's now independent or he's
just doing this all from a mental
institution i'm not sure um he retweeted
that clip that we just showed you uh of
the view and he said they are uh he's
talking about now of course uh tulsi and
tucker they are russian ascents assets
and there is a war there is a case for
detaining them militarily trials are a
sign of good faith and patience on the
part of democracy okay first off i just
want to be clear we are not at war with
russia right now now maybe we're in a
proxy war there is no war that has been
declared right congress has not declared
war biden has made a point of saying we
are not going to war now with all the
sanctions and all the craziness and the
artillery we're sending and all the
things going on behind the scenes maybe
we are at war and it's just not you know
been signed off on war send it over um
but we technically are not at war can
you pull the tweet up one more time so
that's why what he's saying here is so
dangerous they are russian assets first
of us he has no information on that
right he has no evidence that tulsi
gabbard and tucker crossing just because
they don't want to go to war and they're
not repeating everything that the
machine is telling them to repeat
that they are russian assets that's
number one there is a case for detaining
them militarily really think
really think what he is saying he wants
the army to go to people's private homes
tucker carlson you may not like tucker
carlson i happen to like him but you may
not like him you may not agree with him
but the idea that the military could
bust into this guy's house and be and
detain him for just sharing his opinion
on what's going on in a war
that apparently we're not part of in
another part of the world
dangerous dangerous stuff but you know
what don't take my word for what tulsi
and tucker believe tulsi went on
tucker's show to explain it
what would be your response to mitt
romney
well first of all i think it's important
to point out here that this is not a
matter of disagreement or holding a
dissenting view
this is about facts and this is about
the truth so while senator romney and
all these different talking heads in the
in the mainstream media are
regurgitating hillary clinton's
slanderous talking points
the facts remain number one is they're
accusing me of saying that somehow there
are bioweapons
labs in ukraine i've said no such thing
at any point i have said that there are
bio labs in ukraine that have received
u.s support that contained dangerous
pathogens that if those labs are
breached then then we in the world are
facing a potential future of pandemics
the second thing they're saying is they
deny even though there is a plethora of
evidence that exists they deny that
these bio labs are even there
which is shocking to me that you we've
heard over and over you played so many
clips from people in the mainstream
media saying these bio labs these
supposed bio labs as though there's some
fantasy
when over and over and over again
officials from our own government
department of state department of
defense and so on are saying
these bio labs in ukraine
have dangerous pathogens and we're very
concerned that they may be breached
all right so there is tulsi gabbard
calmly explaining
what she explained in the first place
what our secretary of state for
political affairs victoria newman said
under oath to marco rubio that i just
showed you these bio labs exist they are
not bioweapons labs but the question is
if they were to blow up or whatever is
being studied there was to be taken out
and exposed to the world what would
happen
so mitt romney is lying the ladies of
the view are completely insane and then
there's this guy adam kinzinger you may
know adam kinzinger he is a he's a
republican but what i would say is he's
sort of a pet republican he's one of
these republicans who never defends any
conservative values or any republican
principle he basically just goes on
msnbc and gets pet on the head and they
feed him a cookie and then the media
loves him because he's he's really a
democrat that's what he is so he
retweeted that video that i just showed
you of uh tulsi
on tucker and he wrote both are an
embarrassment and a shame traitorous
activity why is fox news still allowing
tucker carlson to spew lies for putin i
know it will cost in ad revenue but fox
news should suspend or cancel his show
okay so again he's calling them
treasonous for repeating facts like we
just played you all the video including
our own secretary of state
and they're treasonous according to
these ridiculous people he went on in
another tweet this clown uh actual
russian propaganda this is he's you can
see he's retweeting tulsi's twitter
thread about what's going on actual
russian propaganda traitorous russia
also said the luger center in georgia
was making zombies tulsi should go to
russia these people are
i don't know what we're going to do
about this you know like this is this is
just more fuel for this sort of
separation of america that they live in
an alternate reality facts don't matter
like facts do not matter to these people
because they just lie they just lie and
they call them traitors and treasonous
even when everything that tulsi said was
absolutely true and it's just it's
russian propaganda if you don't go along
with what the machine wants it's not
just that you're a racist anymore you're
not just a homophobe or a bigot or a
transformer or anything else now you're
a russian asset and maybe we should send
the military to come get you well then
you know what happened and this is just
such a beautiful moment
tucker carlson did the right thing
something that i try to do very often on
this show when he sees people lying or
misinforming people or falsely accusing
people of things he invites them on his
show
he invited adam kinzinger on his show
and here is adam kingsinger's response
i got an invitation to do tucker
carlson's show tonight
and there's no way i'll go on a show for
a number of reasons
but first let me state that his
insistence that the west was provoking
war with putin
his spreading lies about biolabs
and his continued spewing of conspiracy
theories
are nothing but complete evil
his show is full of russian propaganda
and not news
and i will not validate his show by
making an appearance he's not interested
in conversations he's only interested in
himself
and at the end of the day he'll continue
to use his platform to deceive his all
too trusting viewers and to further his
own sense of power
the situation in ukraine is serious and
the outlook is dire
and this moment requires serious
conversation and decisive action so
rather than validate his propaganda
programming i'm gonna use my effort to
support the ukrainian people tucker has
made it clear he stands with putin and
his war against freedom
i stand with ukraine
democracy and the men and women willing
to fight and die for their country
man they are everything they purport the
rest of us to be he is a propagandist
tucker is inviting him on the show i
have no doubt in my mind no doubt that
tucker would gladly do that interview
live
and unedited just as i would do it okay
he is inviting him on for conversation
and this guy is saying no i will not
have conversation as he lies about the
bio lab thing like he brought up the bio
lab thing and claimed tucker's lying
about it you know it's not a lie like
this is what they do and he won't be on
his propaganda show what he means by
propaganda is oh tucker just has a
different view of what's going on there
that's all he means
these people
this is dangerous stuff but this guy
continues so the only reason i'm even
bringing up this guy i don't think i've
ever mentioned adam kinzinger on the
show before because he's also not
running again for congress because
nobody likes him his own base the
conservative republican base in illinois
doesn't even like him so this guy's on
his way out anyway so he's what he's
really doing is just doing his best to
get an msnbc or cnn contributor gig can
you guys make sure we clip this because
i guarantee you when this guy steps down
that's what he's going to get he'll be a
host or a contributor on msnbc or cnn we
will put the date on it and that's what
dave rubin said because it's just
obvious that's how this ridiculous swamp
game is run so he's making the rounds
this guy he was on cnn talking about how
it's us that have to pay more we should
all be paying more
in energy
the community for energy and commerce
we've heard you know a number of people
talking about on both sides of the aisle
pushing for a ban on russian oil and gas
the u.s
do you agree with that idea of a ban and
do you think it's something that that
actually
might happen
i think it's it's certainly gaining
steam i think it should happen
absolutely the american people have to
be ready for even higher energy prices i
think you know there's an understanding
of that this is in essence a small price
to pay particularly if you look at
what's going on in ukraine and you put
yourself in their shoes that's a cost of
defending freedom
and we have over
maybe as of today you know 700 million
some barrels in the strategic petroleum
reserve that's what this is for for
these moments i think we have to do it
this is the one thing that russia
actually makes money on is their energy
and so it may be painful but i think we
absolutely have to ban those imports
guys you just have to pay more for our
inept administration you just have to
pay more you just have to pay eight
dollars for gas we don't know how for
how long you're gonna have to pay more
but you do it's the price for freedom
look this is not to defend russia's
actions you cannot invade a sovereign
nation just because you want to putin
has the idea of greater russia right he
wants to return to 50 years ago and the
soviet union and all those things this
in no way is a defense of putin or his
actions but it is our own
administration's ineptitude that has led
to all of these gas prices and now they
are trying to collapse our economy so
they can usher in their green energy and
their electric cars and all of those
things and they have pumped so much
imaginary money into the economy that we
know inflation is crazy it's 7.5 percent
but now people are saying it could
really be as high as 10 percent that's
that's what's coming out today that when
they're telling you 7.5 there's actually
a lot of indicators that show that it's
closer to 10 which means you have 10 per
however much money you think you have in
your bank account right now go look at
your chase account you have 10 less you
have 10 percent less right now as the
cost of things continue to rise right so
we all know meats going up chickens
going up all goods and services all
going up on top of the fact that the
supply chain stuff the stores don't have
as much stuff your money is worth less
and the price of things is going higher
but don't worry guys don't worry guys
joe biden's on it because you know none
of this could possibly be his fault
make no mistake
the current spike in gas prices is
largely the fault of vladimir putin
it has nothing to do with the american
rescue plan
liar liar your dementia pants are on
fire
it has nothing to do with the american
rescue plan it has nothing to do with
the fact that we just print money more
and more money and we just put it into
the economy and it just sort of sits
there and exists and people don't go to
work and nothing's really working it has
nothing to do with that when you print
money you deflate the value of money in
the first place
they are trying to destroy the dollar
and i honestly think they're trying to
destroy america i really do at this
point they are trying to destroy the
america we all know and we all knew
that's what they're trying to do and
they lie to us about absolutely
everything so they when they lie to you
about gender
and then you accept it well then next
thing you know they're lying to you
about bio labs whether they existed or
not and then they're lying to you about
what inflation actually is and what
happens when you endlessly print money
money that we don't have in the first
place it's not like we got a whole bunch
of money just sitting somewhere and
occasionally we're going in and taking
it right like we've got this nest egg
somewhere of all this money that we've
done that we've done gone saved right
and every now and again we're like ah we
do need more because you know times are
struggling right now there is this war
like let's go into the the reserves and
pull out some money we're just borrowing
more and more money and deflating the
value of american currency that's
what we are doing right now but you know
thank you joe it's not your fault it's
because of russia it's because of russia
right it has nothing to do with you
canceling the keystone xl pipeline which
would have up 800 000 barrels of oil
from canada which now is some of it's
coming uh via railroad but it's like
there were 10 000 jobs that were lost
because of this thing we could have more
oil flowing we all know this we can
unleash america's resources we've got a
lot of oil here but no no no no because
they're telling you actually we're
trying to rejigger the entire economy
actually we're trying to make sure we go
to electric uh cars and all of these
things that's what uh i think pete buda
judge gay pete said we're gonna have 500
000 electric
car charging stations i don't know if
we're gonna have that many cars because
we can't build anything and we can't get
microchips from taiwan but that's a
whole other thing anyway
to finalize the show today uh i want to
do two things first i want to show you
this clip of uh the democratic debate
back in 2019 because i think this was
almost the very moment that the democrat
party went completely insane so you may
remember uh the democrats they had a
whole bunch of people running for
president against the scary orange man
there was biden who was always the
front-runner but then when they realized
he was sort of broken remember that
month where they put bloomberg in and
they pretended that was real and then
they had elizabeth warren and they had
tulsi and they had kamala and they had
gay pete and a couple other people
there was a really powerful moment in
one of the early debates where tulsi
just destroyed kamala and this is a real
moment where the powers that be in the
democratic party could have said which
way are we going to go after we give by
the nomination because they all decided
to give buy it in the nomination
remember when right the day before super
tuesday everybody just dropped out and
supported by it and right like it was a
plan okay it's just how it's how
politics works that's just how it is
but they had another
uh
another possibility the possibility
could have been okay we're going to
select joe biden but we could take a
decent moderate
a decent moderate who loves america
who's a member of our armed services um
hussein
and thoughtful and interesting we could
take her or we could take kamala harris
so i think this moment back in 2019 when
tulsi smackdown kamala is worthy of
revisiting
senator harris says she's proud of her
record as a prosecutor and that she'll
be a prosecutor president but i'm deeply
concerned about this record
there are too many examples to cite but
she put over 1500 people in jail for
marijuana violations and then laughed
about it when she was asked if she ever
smoked marijuana
she blocked evidence
she blocked evidence that would have
freed an innocent man from death row
until the courts forced her to do so she
kept people in prison beyond their
sentences to use them as cheap labor for
the state of california and she fought
to keep cash bail system in place that
impacts poor people in the worst kind of
way
you had your choice democrats you had
your choice you chose the wrong way and
i have no doubt that kamala harris right
now is licking her chops thinking how
can she jail tulsi oh my god whoopi said
i could jail her i'm going to try to
figure
a couple comments from
reubenreport.locals.com and then i think
we're going to show you the we're going
to do it we're going to do it the people
want to see the clip up top again okay
the the wig the lipstick the blouse they
want to see all of it we're going to end
with that a couple comments from the
locals community uh i can't believe you
found my ex she hasn't changed much you
would address yeah well she's she's a
good-looking woman and and she makes
more sense than those other women on the
view i mean that's the simple thing like
me trying to act like a drunken crazy
person responding to those lunatics
makes more sense than those lunatics in
the first place that tells you the state
of where we're at amy says tulsi is way
too patriotic and calm to succeed in the
dc swamp look that's a depressing
reality and i think you're probably
right i mean the the democrat machine
just completely tossed her to the side
by the way when they're calling her a
russian asset right now this is what
this is what hillary clinton did during
the campaign hillary was doing it so
lady if you've got the evidence drop it
right now right as you've got whoopi
goldberg
uh calling for her to be arrested and
and mitt romney saying she's a traitor
and treasonous
um and you're saying that she's a
traitor in treason hillary drop the
evidence how about you drop the evidence
but they know they can just say the most
evil [ __ ] about people and get away with
it because they are in bed with the
media that's what the machine is and if
you step outside of that the machine
will try to destroy you
and and we have to we have to know that
like we really have to know that so that
you know that anytime they say anything
about anyone who doesn't follow the
narrative you know they're lying you
know they're lying whether they're
calling jo uh joe rogan a racist or
they're calling tulsi gabbard a uh you
know treasonous it's like you know they
are lying this is what they do
this is what they do and you gotta
respect it so that you know how to
respond to it uh jeff says has mitt gone
down the biden cognitive road i don't
think mitt is there yet i just think
he's i just think he stands for nothing
other than the power structure right i
think that that's really what drives
mitt romney i think he's nothing he's an
ineffectual
absolute nothing who would never really
stand up and defend any
republican or conservative principle he
likes that the machine likes him and i
understand that by the way
you can all understand the allure of
that it seems like the machine always
wins so it's like at some point people
just kind of give up and they're just
like uh all right i'll just give in to
the machine and then when you see the
way the machine treats the outliers you
know it's not fun i've discussed it
watch my last interview with tucker
carlson from a few months ago
it's not fun to be called a racist every
day it's not fun to be called a
homophobe and a bigot and all those
things i get called that every freaking
day it's not the most fun thing in the
world i can see why a certain amount of
people are just like i can't take it
anymore i'll just power at the talking
points
that's what i'll do that's what i'll do
i promise you i will not do that i will
gladly find something else to do before
i do that
guys you can pre-order my new book don't
burn this country it's coming out on
april 12th pre-order it would ya do me a
favor do me a solid pre-order the book
you're gonna dig it it's fun i did the
audio book it's it's fun it's
informative it really is a solution it's
a series of solutions to so many of the
problems we're talking about right now
um and you know i wrote this thing like
a year ago so it's fun to like get back
into it again and do the audiobook and i
think it's in weird ways it's more
relevant now it's more relevant now
because the machine has just gone
crazier uh so daverubin.com book and uh
join us if you want to play along during
the live chat at reubenreport.locals.com
and part one of my interview with former
u.s ambassador to germany and acting
secretary of intelligence uh rick
grinnell director of intelligence i
should say acting
director of intelligence rick grinnell
part one is up on youtube and rumble
right now the full thing is up ad free
over at local locals
that's it i guess uh what do you think
guys maybe i'll put on the wig and the
lipstick and the blouse again and we'll
go to shake shack
see ya
oh and look i i but i think that's an
incredibly relevant question and i think
doj in the same way that it is setting
up a task force to investigate oligarchs
should look into people who are russian
propagandists and shilling for putin
that's being if you are a foreign asset
to a dictator it should be investigated
in fact i remember when tulsi gabbard
and i even hate that we're discussing it
because i think to myself who is this
woman she's a you know she's no longer
in congress she's a failed presidential
candidate she only practically exists on
twitter and the fact that we're giving
her oxygen is what makes her relevant
that we're talking about her on hot
topics but on the other hand how do you
not call out something that is repeating
false russian propaganda that has been
brought down they used to arrest people
for doing stuff like this if they
thought you were
uh colluding with a russian agent if
they thought you were putting out
information or taking information and
handing over to russia they used to
actually investigate stuff like this and
i guess now you know there seems to be
no bars what are you two crazy [ __ ]
talking about what are you talking about
you want to arrest people who are
different than you politically tulsi
gabbard she's a member of our military
she's a former congresswoman a democrat
you just don't like her so you want to
arrest her you ought to arrest tucker
carlson the very dapper tucker carlson
what are you saying you guys are nuts
you're you're just nuts i only agreed to
do this show because i thought that
whoopi whoopie was sane she was good
sister
sister act two
anna's just nuts i don't even know what
she's doing here and the other ones the
racist the
there's the drunk one
what if what are we all doing here
you people are everything that you've
come to hate you know that
why am i here
i need a haircut
okay that's better